so i understand that the name that the
police have of the suspect who was
arrested on suspicion of the of murder
is
ali harby ali
we know that he is a 25 year old we
reported yesterday he's a british
citizen with somali heritage
and he's in police custody
he's obviously being questioned by the
police it's the counter-terrorism police
that are in the lead on this
investigation
um uh we don't know more about the
motivation or or anything more about um
the reasons why this happened but um i
understand that he as things stand was
not previously known to the security
services but clearly um
investigators are going to be pouring
over what they can find out and and
obviously that situation can change but
as was reported yesterday i i understand
and this was first reported by the
guardian newspaper that the suspect was
um previously uh part of well introduced
to the government's prevent programme
which is
about anti-extremism and the guardian
reported that that was a a while back
now but as things stand um the name that
the police have of this suspect is
believed to be ali harvey ali and he is
not thought to have previously been
known to the security services